[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: In this
small Japanese town,
residents take the concept
of recycling very seriously.
KAZUYUKI KIYOHARA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
NARRATOR: They
separate their trash
into a whopping 34 categories.
KAZUYUKI KIYOHARA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE
NARRATOR: Welcome to Kamikatsu,
Japan, the zero waste town.
HATSUE KATAYAMA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
NARRATOR: Hatsue Katayama
diligently separates her waste
according to Kamikatsu's
rigorous, zero waste program.
HATSUE KATAYAMA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
AKIRA SAKANO: In
the very beginning,
Kamikatsu was doing
open incineration.
But people could
see that's really
hurting the environment
at the same time
the health of the people.
So general waste was created.
NARRATOR: Since the
program began in 2003,
80% of the town's garbage gets
recycled, reused, or composted.
The rest goes to a landfill.
But by 2020, the goal is
to be 100% zero waste.
HATSUE KATAYAMA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
AKIRA SAKANO: It's
been very tough,
in a way, to gain the
understanding of the people.
Of course, when they
had to separate garbage
into 34 categories, which is
massive, it's really tough.
NARRATOR: Residents must
washed, clean, sort, and then
bring all of the materials to
the city's recycling center
where monitors such
as Kazuyuki Kiyohara
make sure it's
being done properly.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
KAZUYUKI KIYOHARA:
NARRATOR: Signs on
each of the bins
tell consumers what their
trash will be recycled into,
and how much that process can
cost or earn the community.
HATSUE KATAYAMA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
NARRATOR: The town has
what's known as a [JAPANESE]
shop, meaning circular, were
residents can bring in and take
used items for free.
There's also a factory where
local women make products out
of discarded items.
AKIRA SAKANO: We have
lots of old kimonos
or old clothes or these
flags not used anymore.
So we asked all these
grannies, who really
had the skills for the sewing.
Then they made it into a craft
like teddy bears or bags,
or what I'm wearing
right now, as well.
It's made out of
all these fish flags
that we celebrate and use
for the Children's Day.
NARRATOR: Businesses
all over Kamikatsu
have incorporated ways
to become zero waste.
AKIRA SAKANO: We are cutting,
by doing the recycling, the cost
into one third compared to when
we actually burned everything.
We are trying to focus more, and
totally change our lifestyles,
to not to produce any waste.
Even in this small town
with only 1,700 people,
everyone looks up to each other.
And they look after and
take care of each other.
So this kind of
supporting system
that was in the
community really helped
for the implementation
of the zero waste.
NARRATOR: Let us
know if you have
any unique tips for reducing
your environmental impact
in the comments below.
And be sure to check
out this next episode.
SPEAKER: Two years of trash
in this tiny little jar.
In my values are having a
really low environmental impact.
I have to live like I want that.
And so that's why I decided
to change my lifestyle.
NARRATOR: Thanks for
watching Seeker Stories.
Please subscribe to see
new videos every week.